wild savage and unstoppable the Norse
berserkers were almost more beasts than
man these Warriors were once just men
but through their ritualistic practices
they acquired powers that made them more
than just a formidable foe there have
been many tales of these wild men who
charged into battle wearing nothing but
the fur of animals who feel no pain or
fear the berserker warriors are known
for being able to enter a rage field
trance their bodies would convulse their
teeth would grind and chatter until the
rage had taken over their bodies would
even change color with their faces
turning a dark red or purple to match
the intense rage while stillness trance
the berserkers are believed to have
superhuman strength and speed they were
almost unstoppable as they were able to
ignore pain being able to fight through
cuts slashes and even the loss of limbs
ignoring wounds that would render a
normal man useless they have been
described as almost possessed while in
this state and sometimes they cannot
discern the difference between enemy and
Ally there are varying explanations for
the behavior of the Berserker warriors
some believe their practices to be
similar to that of shamans or druids
sharing a bond with nature and its
surroundings they believe that an animal
spirit can live on after death and
through wearing the fur pelts of animals
the berserk Warriors are emboldened gain
in what they believe to be the animal
strength and abilities the pelt of a
bear was thought to give him in strength
and courage the wolf's ferocity and
prowess and the stag guile and speed
although these Berserker Warriors are
part of a tribe or pack they clearly
preferred the company of animals they
would only ever harm animals in times of
famine and the animal sacrifice was
someone of a ritual they would often
drink the blood of the animal
symbolizing the parson of life and
strength
these type of as Urkel warriors would
often wield large hammers and axes or
even duel hatchets weapons that could be
swung around wildly with little or no
concern of their surroundings this could
also be seen in their wild and
unpredictable fighting style there is a
possibility that the werewolf legend
could have originated from the Berserker
warriors essentially transforming from
man to beast in battle
these Berserker Warriors were often used
as frontline shock troops they would
often be sent to disrupt and shock the
enemy sometimes even causing them to
flee just with their sheer ferocity some
historians believe that the behavior of
the Berserker warriors does have a
scientific explanation opposed to being
possessed by animal spirits the
Berserker warriors frenzy of rage and
uncontrollable anger may have been
caused from the consumption of the plant
bog Myrtle a spice used in alcoholic
beverages combined with other
hallucinogenics that they may have
inhaled in the wild
berserkers may have been under the
influence of alcohol or drug like
substances this would explain their
disregard for pain and unpredictable
behavior there is a tale from Icelandic
poet who mentions a berserker warrior
who ate his own shield in the middle of
battle when he was done he then killed
six other men there is no definitive
proof to whether the Berserker Warriors
charged into battle possessed by the
spirits of animals or in a self-induced
trance caused by alcohol and other
hallucinogenics it is down to your own
interpretation the risen of a type of
Berserker which much closer resembles a
Viking warrior these Warriors worship
the Norse god Odin these berserkers were
considered to be born warriors with a
thirst for battle in battle these
Warriors were still similar entering
rage-filled trances but it's believed
that these trances were driven by their
need to be victorious there was no
greater honor to them and taken a man's
life in battle
whether you believe that the Berserker
Warriors had magical gifts bestowed upon
them by animal spirits or that there
were just a bunch of drunk crazy Vikings
they were undoubtedly fierce warriors
who were feared by enemies everywhere
and even allies if you were unlucky
enough to come face-to-face with a
berserker it is likely that their face
would be the last you'd ever see if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained